kyle shanahan the 49ers coach yesterday
spoke to the media one of the things he
said and i think this is true and it's
and it's good to hear it come from
someone like kyle shanahan
white america
had previously not paid the kind of
attention to these issues as it is now
we're waking up to these issues we're
understanding the problem like never
before and he was very candid about that
he was also candid about the lack of
minority coaches and general managers in
the nfl here's shanahan on that topic
how the heck are there four only four
black coaches out of 32 head coaches how
they're only two gm's
i mean we're in a predominantly i mean
the majority of our players are black so
the fact that there's that few
i mean that's not debatable like i don't
know if people are openly thinking
they're doing it which i think that
people sort to that but that's what the
problem is i mean that number is not
debatable and that's that is an issue
and i think we talk about it a lot
um
and it is something that has to get
better i i know they've thrown out a
bunch of stuff i know
i only speak for myself i i try to
you know i try to hire people that i
work with that are prepared for it and
fortunately that's worked out well for
me i've got
got a muslim coach we got a muslim
coordinator we got a black coordinator
uh
we have a lesbian on our staff uh we
have we have everything and it's not
just to show people that we're trying to
be diverse it's just because i've been
around these people and they are really
good at what they do and i can't we
can't win without these people and
that's just how it works out i don't
know why
the numbers aren't like that but the
numbers are
are wrong and that's stuff that
hell yeah we want to fix but it's it's
not an easy answer it's continuing to
talk continuing to
the whole thing with society everything
it's all it's all very similar on
different levels and that's why those
numbers don't lie that's what makes it a
fact and that's what
white people have to admit
the nfl has been urgently trying to
improve what it has described through
executive vp of football operations troy
vincent as a broken system of minority
hiring of coaches and general managers
that work was happening in earnest
before george floyd's murder i can only
assume that they will be working even
harder to ensure that there are measures
taken to improve those numbers but you
know this is hey this is the kind of
change that that that we are talking
about at every level of society it's not
just an issue of the actions of law
enforcement big cat it is taking a step
back and rooting out all forms of
systemic racism that have truly
prevented our nation from doing justice
to the mottos we hear all the time
liberty and justice for all
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness all men are created equal
it's 244 years late but i think we're
arriving at the moment where those words
are finally going to be applied
literally and seriously
what's the fix mike because it does it
does feel like the rooney rule is um
the the idea of the rooney rule is great
but it doesn't it doesn't feel like
sometimes teams are actually practicing
it earnestly and you saw i'm trying to
think back to some of the recent hirings
but where
you you see a team almost like we've
already decided the guy we want we we
know who we want uh i'm trying to think
like even the cowboys it felt like they
went from jason garrett to might be
coming back to mike mccarthy in a matter
of seconds so
how do you implement something that that
is is great in theory but doesn't seem
like it always works in practice
tony dungy had a great recommendation
when he and i talked about this a couple
of weeks ago and i'll summarize it as
quickly as i can he believes all owners
should be told regardless of whether or
not you're even considering a coaching
change to articulate the attributes they
want in a coach and to basically have
that on file this is what i want in a
coach these are the six seven things i'm
looking for
then when the time comes to consider
making a change the first thing you do
is you compare the coach you have to the
attributes you're looking for and if you
decide that coach no longer has those
attributes then you work with the league
and there would be a panel and that
would be it would basically be a
matchmaking service here are the guys
who have the attributes that you're
looking for and it doesn't matter what
their background is it doesn't matter
what they look like these are the men
who can do what it is that you're
looking for that was his suggestion and
i think it just takes something like
that to to get past that notion that
hey it's the billionaire's privilege
i'll do what i want i'll hire who i want
we have to we have to get them to press
pause and take a broader view as to what
their their overall
expectations are what their objectives
are and how best to find the right
person regardless of who i'm the most
comfortable with or who it is that i see
on tv that that i want to be my coach
regardless of whether or not they really
know anything about who the person
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports